c'est l'objectif de chaque mariée mettre
les petits plats dans les grands
une spécialité pour ce traiteur de
montigny le bretonneux cocktail lui
pièce entrée et plat et buffet de
desserts tous a réalisé avec des
produits locaux alors en pièces cocktail
par exemple on va travailler sur une
pièce kfc féminine
c'est une brochette de une pince de
radis noir avec une crevettes marinées à
la menthe
c'est très fred légèrement croquants
très féminin nous avons également un
ceviche de saumon aux pertes de news où
nous avons un rôle important dans une
réception de mariage
de par la qualité de la prestation au
niveau du service mobilité des gens être
à l'écouté des clients être le plus
discret possible et également au niveau
de l'art culinaire et de l'art de la
table
il faut que nous soyons à la hauteur des
attentes des clients et pour conclure le
festin des mariés place à la pièce
montée une tradition né au xviiie siècle
est toujours d'actualité pour un coût
qui oscille entre 400 et 1000 euros
une activité symbolique pour ce
pâtissier la pièce montée c'est ce que
ça représente pour un mariage va sceller
fait ou est ce que les gens ont vraiment
le bouquet final du mariage le dessert
qui étant attendues après avoir réalisé
les choux c'est le moment de les garnir
avec une crème pâtissière un peu
particulière en fait on utilise de la
vanille bourbon
car plus qu'un goût à 13 euros matic car
un goût très particulier pour la crème
pâtissière et qui la différencie de ses
une crème pâtissière classique avec une
poche et une douille donc je vais en
format poche de crème pâtissière et
après je vais percer juste le dessous du
show et je veux venir remplir devant
pour glacer les choux damien utilise un
caramel à base de glucose une technique
pour travailler plus facilement le
caramel donc là maintenant je passais au
montage donc je récupère un petit show
je viens lui trop lu glace et le
le côté dans le caramel je rappelais
bien et je déposer délicatement sur
vannes ou gastines voilà plus on grimpe
plus le montage devient délicat pour
décorer cette montagne de chou damien
utilise du sucre tiré pour fabriquer des
rubans vient ensuite la touche finale
avant de pouvoir faire craquer les
invités
[Musique]